okay so who's like the first person that
you looked up to in terms of skin care
in regards to like a man no man no man
really right no unfortunately I I didn't
even know that was a thing like let me
ask you something like you know how we
found out as we get over like girls love
men with like manicures and pedicures
and stuff like that like is skincare a
big thing with when it comes to women I
mean women always love men because skin
I mean come on but as much as you guys
think about your your nails and your
skin we think about that too so of
course
it's a big deal for us
dang that's what's up I guess it does
reflect a lot about your personality
or